And we'll be chanting Namo Tassa, Bhagavato, Arahato, Sama, Sambuddhassa.
Okay?
You all with me?
Thank you.
When we get to the stupa, the monks at the top will lead us in the three refuges and precepts.
And then a reading will be made of the first discourse of the Buddha,
and then we'll make our way down to the statue of Kuan Yin and there we'll have a reading of the Metta Sutta and a chanting of it.
And then we'll make our way back to the Marquis and there we'll listen to some talks.
And then at the end of it we'll have a cup of tea.
You'll find all you need for chanting on the back page of this handout.
So we'll begin the little ceremony by our chanting.
Namo Tassa Mahato Mahato Sammasambuddhassa
Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samma-sambuddhassa
Satsang with Mooji
CHOIR SINGS
.
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
pāhuneyo pāhuneyo dakhineyo anjali-karaneyo manottaraṁ puṇyākhetāṁ lokasādhi
etena satyavanchena sathutam ratanatayam etena satyavanchena sathutam ratanatayam etena satyavanchena sathutam ratanatayam
nīvāṁ me sutāṁ hekaṁ samayāṁ bhagavāḥ sāvattyāṁ viharati te tavaṇe anātha pindi kaśyārāṇe ātako anyatarāṁ
Satsang with Mooji
Venerable Maitreya Guruji
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
Sivanāca pālānāṁ pānditānāṁ ca sevana pūjāca pūjaniyānāṁ etāṁ maṅgala-muttamāṁ pati-rūpa-deśa-vāso ca
Subha Sita Chayava Chaitamangalamutramam
Svātāgītu vātānaṁ pūrtalāraṁ ca saṅgāho anākulā ca kammaṁ tārītāṁ āṅgalaṁ uttamaṁ tānaṁ ca tamma-cāriyā ca nyāta-kāraṁ
Satsang with Mooji
Sādhu ca sāntur ki ca kathānyukta Kāle na dhamma sādhang etāng māṅgalamutta māṅkānti ca sovacā sādhā Sāmenānāṅ ca daśanāṅ
Thank you for watching.
He is the Lord of the Universe.
Sambhadra Sambhadra Sambhadra Sambhadra
etena sāccha vajjena ho tu te jaya-mangala
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
Sakyamuni Sakyamuni Sakyamuni Sakyamuni
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
nās sāntu pāntavaḥ saṁdhi-vayābhūpa-saṁhintute sāt-kathvāḥ saṅga-ratnaṁ hosadam uttamaṁ vāṇā ābhūneyaṁ pābhūneyaṁ saṅgade
Oh,
Tasmā sūtti bhavantute ānkenchi rathānandoke vijyati vividhā putu rathānandam samān nāt Tasmā sūtti bhavantute ānkenchi rathānandoke vijyati vividhā putu
Attenang sanggesamang hati tasna sotibawantute Nattime saranang anyang utome saranang warang Iti nasat jawarjena hotute jayamanggelang Nattime saranang anyang tango
Satsang with Mooji
Oh Oh
Subtitles by the Amara.org community
So make sure that you can pick up one of the Josh sticks there at the corner and just follow the procession.